we are we're going about to go into
flavor tripping which we take berries
and see what happens supposed to change
our taste buds by encoding them
I'd like to introduce to you our
gracious host and the man who put this
fantastic event together a mustache
commander from the shadow government's
Francesco welcome you are courageous
soul to present your stomach with the
amount of acidity that's about to a head
is going to be painful we will provide
antacids on the way out otherwise you
know i don't want to say too much
because you're not here to hear me talk
you're here to look at my beautiful
mustache I understand so you're cheering
the berry how long you been sure in the
berry park right what does it taste like
watermelon Jolly Ranchers
are you buying it if they're working
would be a civic groups three honest get
it still exists different but there are
some things like that don't really
change like what didn't change cheese
didn't seem to change much I don't know
if it's actually working it's amazing
it's really trippy are you buying it so
far not something's definitely something
sort of like lemon lime definitely yeah
but what about what you say is like
there's a belief convincing part of the
experience let me take like tastes like
lemonade the pickles taste like him
being there
and we're getting
the holidays like bacon like what were
you expecting
crazy crazy
you betcha
watch out
go fix a second five I've eaten my berry
with the protein that's most have coded
my tongue but I'm now trying at this
lemon
that is very sweet taste like I mean it
does not taste like lemon it almost
seems like Cardiff a double seems like a
lemonhead with the sour turned way now
Saavik vinegar
I could drink that all day lipstick say
I mean please be totally disgusting when
I get your get all this going here we go
this is true bravery on behalf of your
wired com correspondent this is a boy
stur with lemon all a bitter right now
all right
don't go itself
Tony the show
wow I are there there's a little bit
like lemon sherbert she has tequila
tequila
very slowly settling
I still think Matt tequila seems like
magic healing nicely actually hot she's
going to sum it up for it like what do
you think do you think this actually
works and even get just sort of like a
kind of collective hallucination would
you do it again for twenty-five dollars
i would wear you buy from the wholesaler
I have a flagpole Singler and do it all
the time yeah
you